In this video I want to give
you an example of what it
means to fit data to a line.
Instead of doing my traditional
video using my
little pen tablet, I'm going to
do it straight on Excel so
you could see how to do this for
yourself, so if you have
Excel or some other type of
a spreadsheet program.
We're not going to go
into the math of it.
I really just want you to get
the conceptual understanding
of what it means to fit data
with line, or do a linear
regression.
So here, let's just
read the problem.
The following table shows the
median California income--
remember median is the middle,
the middle California income
--from 1995 to 2002
as reported by
the U.S. Census Bureau.
Draw a scatter plot and
find the equation.
What would you expect the median
annual income of a
California family to be
in the year 2010?
What are the meanings of the
slope and the y-intercept of
this problem?
So the first thing you'd want
to do-- I just copied and
pasted this image --we have to
get the data in a form that
the spreadsheet can
understand it.
So let's make some
tables here.
Let's say years since 1995.
Let's make that one column.
Let me make this a
little bit wider.
Then let me put median income.
This is the median income in
California for a family.
So we start off with 1 year,
or 0 years since
1995, 0, 1, 2, 3, 4.
Actually if you want, it'll
figure out the trend if you
just keep going down.
It'll figure out you're just
incrementing by 1.
Then the income, I'll
just copy in these
numbers right there.
So that's $53,807, $55,217,
$55,209, $55,415 $63,100,
$63,206, $63,761, and then
we have $65,766.
So I don't need these
over here.
So I'm going to get
rid of them.
I can clear them.
So let me make sure I
have enough entries.
This is 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8,
and I have 1, 2, 3, 4, 5,
6, 7, 8 entries.
I want to make sure I got my
data right. $53,807, $55,217,
$55,209, 415, 100,
206, 761, 766.
OK, there we go.
Now you're going to find that
in Excel this is incredibly
easy if you know what
to click on.
One, plot this data, create a
scatter plot, and then even
better, create a regression
of that data.
So all you have to do is
you select the data.
Then you go to insert,
and I'm going to
insert a scatter plot.
Then you can pick the different
types of scatter plots.
I just want to plot the data.
There you go.
It plotted the data for me.
If you go by this is the actual
income, and this is by
year since 1995.
So this is 1995.
It was $53,807.
In 1996 it's $55,217.
So it plotted all the data.
Now what I want to
do is fit a line.
So this isn't exactly a line.
But let's see, if we assume
that a line can model this
data well, I'm going to get
Excel to fit a line for me.
So what I can do is I have all
of these options up here for
different ways to fit
a line, all of
these different options.
I'm going to pick
this one here.
You might not be
able to see it.
It looks like it has a
line between dots.
It also has fx which tells me
going to tell me the equation
of the line.
So if I click on that,
there you go.
It not only fit, it replotted
that same data
on a different graph.
Let me make it a little
bit bigger.
No, I don't want to that.
Let me make it a little
bit bigger.
We can cover up the data now,
just because I think we know
what's going on.
So let me cover it up
right like that.
So not only did it plot the
various data points, it
actually fit a line to that
data and it gave me the
equation of that line.
Let me see if I can make this
a little bit bigger.
I'll move it out of the way so
you can read it at least.
So it tells me right here, that
the equation for this
line is y is equal to 1,882.3x
plus 52,847.
So if you remember what we
know about slope and
y-intercept, the y-intercept
is 52,847, which is, if you
use this line as your measure,
where this line intersects at
year 0, or in 1995.
So if you use this line as a
model, in 1995 the line would
say that you're going
to make $52,847.
The actual data was a little
bit off of that.
It was a little bit
higher, $53,807.
So it was a little bit higher.
But we're trying to get a line
that gets as close as possible
to all of this data.
It's actually trying to minimize
the distance, the
square of the distance, between
each of these points
in the line.
We won't go into
the math there.
But it gave us this
nice equation.
Now we can use this nice
equation to predict things.
If we say that this is a good a
model for the data-- let me
bring this down a little
bit --let's try
to answer our question.
So we drew a scatter plot--
really Excel did it for us.
We found the equation
right there.
They say, what would you expect
the median annual
income of a California family
to be in the year 2010?
So here, we can just use the
equation they gave us.
This right here, was 2002.
So I could write
down the year.
This was the year of 2002.
So the year 2010 is
8 more years.
Let me make a little
column here.
So this is the year,
1995, 1996.
Then Excel will be able to
figure out if I select those,
and I go to this little bottom
right square and I scroll
down, Excel will actually figure
out that I want to
increment by 1 year
every time.
If I say years since 1995, once
again I can just continue
this trend right here.
So 2010 would be 15 years.
So we can just apply
this equation.
We could say it's going to be
equal to, according to this
line-- I'm just going to type it
in, hopefully you can read
what I'm saying --1,882.3
times x.
x here is the year since 1995.
I could just select this
cell, or I could type
in the number 15.
That means times this
cell, times 15.
Then plus 52,847, plus
that right there.
Click enter and it predicts
$81,081.50.
So if you just continue this
line for another 8 or so
years, it predicts that the
median income in California
for a family will be $81,000.
Anyway, hopefully you found
that interesting.
Spreadsheets are very useful
tools for manipulating data.
It'll give you a sense of why
linear models are interesting,
why lines are interesting, and
how you can actually use these
tools to interpret data and
maybe even extrapolate some
type of a prediction.
This right here, is an
extrapolation using this
linear regression.